anthony blinken literally wants to have
members of the uncommon judge
american racism that's pathetic and it's
anti-american
it's not about spreading american values
abroad it's not about liberating people
it's about forwarding
democratic domestic political interests
it's all wag the dog crap
alrighty so meanwhile the biden
administration while declaring that you
know american racism is an all-time high
and that jim crow is on the way while
they run the entire government
by the way they are now pursuing that
they're pursuing an anti-american policy
it's an anti-american foreign policy
i don't know how else to describe this
tweet from secretary of state anthony
blanken now
i've given blink and credit in the past
for for example
saying some relatively decent things
about the israel gaza conflict
for example i've given blinken and the
foreign policy team some credit for the
things that joe biden said with regards
to vladimir putin but this is truly
egregious and the fact that it's been
largely overlooked by the media is
insane to me so he tweeted this out
i completely missed this until one of my
producers made me aware of it this
morning it's wild
secretary of state lincoln tweeted this
quote responsible nations must not
shrink from scrutiny of their human
rights record
rather they should be transparent with
the intent to grow and do better
that is why i'm announcing a formal
invitation for the un
special rapporteur on contemporary forms
of racism to visit the united states
this is patently mad i mean it's crazy
the united nations
is a is most easily of international
politics it is a wretched hive of scum
and villainy
the the notion that we should have
auditors from sudan
and china and russia and malaysia and
all of these other countries that
can't hold the candle laws in terms of
human rights come and audit
domestic american racism it's a
political tool by anthony blinken
which so often foreign policy is to
democrats and this is why barack obama
in his very early days before he was
even president did a european tour
you a lot of people in the united states
were saying themselves why is barack
obama a senator in the united states
running for the american presidency
attempting to go abroad and do speeches
in like berlin and paris and the answer
is
because what democrats really wish to do
is suggest that other countries
their opinions ought to matter with
regards to domestic american politics
the rest of the world is judging us
it's sort of greta tuneburg syndrome
writ large they're judging you
that judge and so anthony blinken
literally wants to have members of the
u.n come and judge
american racism that's pathetic and it's
anti-american
no one has the moral stature to come
into the united states
the most racially diverse place on earth
most racially diverse democracy on
planet earth and most racially tolerant
diverse democracy on planet earth by the
way
and then start lecturing us on how
racist we are and the fact that this
administration is welcoming them in
they're welcoming them in in the same
way that the department of justice under
merrick garland
is going to go into police departments
and simply make up reports about how
police departments are racist and then
cram down consent decrees the idea here
will be the u.n issues report
on how terrible and racist america is
and there it is magically
the only way to alleviate this deep and
brutal and abiding racism is to do all
the things that joe biden wants to do
so joe biden and anthony blinken can't
convince you that america is racist and
terrible
so they will bring in international
institutions to call america racist and
terrible
and deride the united states on the
international stage so they can say we
need to do all the things we already
wanted to do
because after all the world expects it
of us it's not who we
are it's so shameless and it's so yucky
okay the the reality is that as i talked
about on the show yesterday and the day
before
to most people who are seeking freedom
on planet earth the united states is the
place you go
the united states is the place you go
for racial tolerance the united states
has a higher household income for
nigerian americans than it does for
white americans has a higher household
income
for asian americans than for white
americans for for a
supposedly white supremacist country
we're doing a horrible job of it here in
the united states
and yet the continuous push from the
democrats that america is deeply racist
and the whole goal here is to mobilize
minority voters who supposedly are going
to fight
the revanchist republican racism that
inevitably will fall
despite the fact that again it does not
exist and it is very silly
now all of this is part and parcel of
treating american foreign policy as
basically a domestic political weapon
it's not about spreading american values
abroad it's not about liberating people
it's not about insuring a safer and more
secure world for american interest it's
not about any of those things it's about
forwarding
democratic domestic political interests
it's all wag the dog crap
it is all about doing things that
benefit the democrats
politically domestically i mean that is
why joe biden is pulling out of
afghanistan make no mistake that is not
about forwarding american interests it's
not about making america more safe and
it is not about protecting american
troops it is about joe biden
wanting to be able to say that he
withdrew from afghanistan unlike all of
his predecessors and then
thinking that the american people are
going to cheer even as women are stuffed
back into burqas
and stuff back into basements and the
taliban take over the country and
continue to foster terrorism in the
region
because joe biden wants the political
win it is that simple
and now when secretary blinken is
welcoming in un special reporters
to talk about american racism you know
how much i care about what the u.n has
to say about anything having to do with
morality
this this turd bucket of an organization
i could not care less
what the u.n has to say about anything
the u.n is a is a
is a despicable
dumpster fire of an organization where
we're supposed to take seriously
countries
like yemen on human rights no the answer
should be by any patriotic president and
any patriotic administration know
but instead we're actively seeking out
the opinions of the un on american
racism which of course is designed
solely to create pressure domestically
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight and top of
your feed